Ciao a tutti grazie grazie per me è un
onore un onore un orgoglio far parte
della Grande famiglia tedesca ed essere
qui con voi a parlare di una delle cose
apparentemente più semplici cioè la
nutrizione quella che appunto noi
genitori nonni tutti si preoccupano se
abbiamo mangiato ma che in realtà
nutrizione è una parola molto importante
molto importante anche perché io la vivo
da ex bancaria oggi chef ormai da un bel
po' di anni da più di un decennio Anche
perché io poi per diventare chef quindi
per fare questo mio percorso si parte
sono partita da una base di curiosità
ovviamente verso la tavola per cui
andavo a cercare un pochino sempre
quello che qualcosa che mi desse
emozioni che quindi mi desse il famoso
effetto wow quindi andava a cercare
ristoranti andavo a cercare posti dove
magari in quel periodo andava di moda
andare a provare quel piatto quello
stile di cucina quelli identità Quindi
io magari andavo super curiosa ga forza
e magari mangiavo una cosa buonissima un
abbinamento strano un piatto nuovo
meraviglioso poi magari tornava a casa
dopo 24 ore ma ero anche dimenticata
cosa avevo mangiato Io mi sono detto ho
cominciato a dirmi ma ma quel cavolo di
effetto wow che tutti cercano tutti noi
vogliamo ecco voi per esempio immagino
come come me quando ero diciamo cliente
quindi da ex bancaria e anche voi sarete
stati nei ristoranti a cercare il famoso
effetto wow quella cucina particolare
Quanti di voi almeno una volta sono
andati in un ristorante a dire son
sicuro che l'effetto Wow lo trovo io
sono sicura che almeno una volta ci
sarete stati tutti in un ristorante a
cercare l'effetto Wow Ma che però
purtroppo ahimè tante volte dopo un paio
di giorni vi siete anche dimenticati
cosa avevate mangiato quindi ho
cominciato
a cercare qualcosa che andasse oltre
quella sorta di spettacolarizzazione
della cucina che poi negli ultimi anni
ha preso piede perché per carità ci apre
il mondo anche magari di altre
nazionalità altre culture che si
abbinano poi a quella che è la nostra
tradizione però per noi è un effetto wow
di passaggio spesso temporaneo
per cui quando ho cominciato a pensare
cos'era realmente quella cosa che mi
dava l'effetto Wow Ma che nutriva oltre
a nutrire la pancia nutriva anche il
cuore la testa quindi ho cominciato un
pochino a pensare a quello che realmente
Io ancora della tavola della cucina
dell'essere nutrita potessi ricordarmi
Anche da lontano allora ho cominciato a
pensare quando ero piccola per esempio
che io appunto avendo una tradizione
molto forte dal punto di vista
gastronomico e non solo perché io sono
di papà Toscano e di mamma pugliese alla
fine io sono nata e cresciuta in Toscana
per cui per andare a fare merenda per
farvi un esempio banale essendo
cresciuta Nella bella campagna toscana
io uscivo con due cose fondamentali per
la mia merenda gli stuzzicadenti mette
un paio di stuzzicadenti in tasca e una
bustina di plastica una bustina del
supermercato legata al manubrio della
bicicletta poi per andare a fare merenda
cosa facevo tanto le contadine della
zona mi conoscevano nel bene e nel male
perché molto spesso andavo a tirar via
le galline per vedere se c'erano le uova
quindi mi aprivano anche le porte
ovviamente del Recinto quindi mi serviva
lo stuzzicadenti Perché Perché buco
sopra buco sotto e facevo merenda con un
uovo me lo strofinavo un attimo su
pantaloni per pulirlo e poi riusciva a
fare merenda oppure banalmente quando
arrivavo nel filare di frutteti o di
verdure raccoglievo quello che c'era di
stagione perché sarà la stagione dei
pomodori facciamo merenda coi pomodori
se c'erano le albicocche rubavo le
albicocche Ma arrampicavo i fichi Mamma
mia e riempivo la busta andavo vicino a
casa poi con gli amichetti e facevo
merenda Ecco quello mi sono resa conto
Poi nel tempo che era il vero effetto
wow perché nella sua semplicità nel suo
essere una cosa molto spesso insomma
anche un po' fuori dalle righe perché
magari contadini a volte venivano a casa
da mia madre a sgridarmi però son quelle
le cose che veramente erano l'effetto
Wow quello che nutriva per me non solo
la pancia ma anche la testa del cuore
perché sono cose che ancora oggi mi
ricordo
e che non vedo l'ora di rivivere Perché
io quando trovo un fico pieno ho bisogno
di arrampicarmi sull'albero per
prenderne uno perché mi fa ricordare
delle cose belle quindi questo era il
vero effetto wow e soprattutto ero anche
una cosa bella perché inconsapevolmente
rispettato me stessa perché comunque
mangiavo cose buone mangiavo cose che in
quel periodo facevano bene perché di
stagione e Rispetto la natura rispettavo
da piccole ho imparato a rispettarla da
grande
questo perché Perché per farvi anche un
altro esempio banalmente cioè d'estate
nascono crescono albicocche meloni
carote e magari tante altre verdure
tante altre i frutti che contengono
naturalmente
betacarotene quello che ci serve In
realtà d'estate perché ci esponiamo al
sole fa caldo sudiamo tanto eccetera
eccetera Ci servono Ovviamente per tener
bene la nostra pelle il nostro corpo o
magari d'inverno che le arance piuttosto
che le brassicace quelle che in tutte le
famiglie che ci hanno figli sono un
problema perché anch'io ho due figli
quindi le prassicace che sono molto
comunemente i broccoli i cavoli Tutte
quelle cose che i bambini un attimino
fanno un po' fatica a mangiare che però
fanno bene perché contengono vitamina C
contengono minerali e casualmente
nascono in autunno e in inverno quindi
ecco un'altra domanda importante è ma
sarà un caso che nascono cavolo le cose
cambiare la vitamina C nascono di
primavera d'estate le cose invece con la
vitamina con la vitamina bilbeta
carotene nascono in primavera c'è cose
con la vitamina C minerali cose che
invece fanno bene al nostro organismo al
nostro corpo nascono D'inverno è un caso
No
questa è un'altra effetto wow
fondamentale che va ben oltre noi stessi
È che la natura sa tutto quindi in
realtà non è che c'è da andare a cercare
a fare chissà quali lavori chissà quali
lavori pindarici che possano stravolgere
la natura perché noi possiamo far bene
la natura se la rispettiamo Ma la natura
naturalmente fa bene a noi perché lei sa
tutto quindi ecco Anche questa è
un'altra effetto wow però veramente che
molto spesso noi ci dimentichiamo perché
dobbiamo andare a cercare qualcosa per
forza fuori stagione Sì possiamo
trovarlo ma molto spesso intanto magari
non avrà tutte quelle vitamine tutte
quelle sostanze che naturalmente
crescono perché magari esposte al sole
quello giusto e poi perché non hanno
quel sapore quel sapore che ci fa
l'effetto Wow dal punto di vista
emozionale cioè banalmente d'estate
mangiamo un pomodoro a morsi Ecco Quanti
di voi hanno magari mangiato tanti
pomodori restando insoddisfatti Questa è
un altro problema perché perché appunto
se non hanno quel sapore non ci
risvegliano Neanche quei ricordi e con i
pomodori con tante altre cose Io per
esempio da piccola sempre in Toscana un
altro momento idilliaco della nostra
storia Toscana ma penso un po' in tante
parti d'Italia anche da voi c'è il
momento della frangitura delle olive
quindi si raccolgono i genitori
raccolgono le olive si fa un bel gruppo
tante famiglie mise insieme e io da
piccola insieme Ovviamente agli
amichetti diciamo ai figli delle altre
famiglie coinvolte noi avevamo quel
giorno la liberatoria assoluta di poter
andare a rubare i pomodori e le
contadine non ci rincorrevano per cui
chiaramente mentre loro raccoglievano le
olive
l'olio tutto quanto noi potevamo andare
a prendere i pomodori che anche lì è
strusciatina sui pantaloni un po' di
morsi e poi un altro Poli portavamo a
casa perché eravamo autorizzati Visto e
considerato che con l'olio nuovo cosa si
doveva fare si fa la pappa al pomodoro
quindi facendo Ecco la pappa al pomodoro
per me che poi spesso andavo ovviamente
ad aiutare a cucinare magari aiutavamo a
tagliare a prendere il basilico a
prendere il pomodoro Poi magari lo
spezzavamo a pezzi e magari anche le
pellicine bruciavano perché ci si
mangiava le unghie se spezzi pomodori la
parte acida del pomodoro Te la ricordi
perché ti brucia poi quelle erano
emozioni quello era effetto wow e quello
mi sono resa conto finalmente facendo il
mio percorso risvegliando tutti questi
ricordi che questi piatti apparentemente
banali semplici ma che fanno parte della
nostra cultura della nostra famiglia
della nostra tradizione E soprattutto
sono dei sapori semplici ma importanti
Ci nutrono e ci nutrono non solo questo
punto di vista alimentare stagionale per
cui che contiene tutta la parte di
vitamine di sostanze che fa bene al
nostro corpo ma ci nutrono qui dentro e
soprattutto Siamo anche in grado oltre a
nutrirci e
a risvegliare tutte queste forti
emozioni riusciamo anche a portarle di
generazione in generazione perché
riusciamo banalmente come io facevo con
mio padre la pappa al pomodoro con mia
madre Io oggi posso farla con i miei
figli E posso portare avanti in maniera
semplice questa grande tradizione che ci
nutre dentro riesce a nutrire la natura
riesce a farci del bene quindi ecco Poi
ci sono tante altre cose Mettici la
fettunta che mi svegliavo di notte papà
papà
e lo svegliavo perché mi preparasse la
fettunta di notte quindi ecco questi
sono dei veri effetti Wow Quindi io
chiedo Ecco anche voi Probabilmente
magari
avrete qualche piatto qualcosa o anche
qualche ricordo che non collegato
puramente e unicamente alla tavola ma
che possa essere un effetto che la
natura vi crea vi dà naturalmente anche
semplicemente vivendo un momento che fa
parte della natura che rispetta la
stagione e soprattutto che voi
attraverso la natura rispettati anche
voi stessi per esempio un altro ricordo
grandissimo che ho
è il fatto che
mia nonna ma penso un po' forse le nonne
di tante famiglie di tanti di voi mia
nonna usava tutto alla lavanda Ecco un
altro degli odori che credo che possa
dare delle emozioni veramente veramente
forti io la prima volta mi sono
ritrovata la prima volta nella vita in
cui mi sono ritrovata in un campo di
lavanda la lavanda Ovviamente era già
Fiorita aveva già quell'odore forte Io
mi sono ritrovata in quel campo io ho
pianto ho pianto perché perché
attraverso un semplice
vogliamo dire banale
profumo di lavanda ho risvegliato dei
ricordi in me che fanno parte ovviamente
di
tanto cuore tante emozioni tanta tanta
tanta parte emotiva che semplicemente
attraverso la natura ovviamente mi si
sono risvegliate quindi ecco io quello
che oggi parlando di nutrizione perché
ovviamente la nutrizione è quello che ci
rende vivi
vorrei che riuscisse a risvegliare in
voi tutto ciò che fa parte della
Nutrizione ma non in Puro e Semplice
nutrimento fisico perché è una cosa che
non è abbastanza importante per noi
principalmente e per la natura perché
molto spesso nutrendo solo il nostro
corpo andiamo a cercare quello che può
soddisfare il nostro palato
Istintivamente e istantaneamente Ma che
molto spesso un po' perché magari in
alcuni casi non rispetta la stagione o
un po' perché non rispetta quelli che è
il nostro gusto reale non non sveglia
neanche i nostri ricordi e quindi non
abbiamo l'effetto Wow quindi Ricordatevi
che il vero effetto wow ce lo dà alla
natura Perché sa tutto e soprattutto ce
lo danno quei piatti quegli odori quei
Sapori e quei profumi che risvegliano in
noi dei ricordi così forti così radicati
che possono dare delle emozioni a noi ma
in pochi passi magari rifacendo quel
piatto e proponendolo anche ad un amico
ad un'amica ai nostri figli se abbiamo
figli possono riportare quelle stesse
emozioni quello stesso effetto wow anche
di generazione in generazione quindi non
dimenticatevelo mai perché il vero
effetto wow Ce l'avete voi qua dentro il
cuore dentro la pancia e attraverso
questo potrete darlo anche a qualcuno
quindi questa è la vera nutrizione
Questo è il vero effetto wow
Io vi ringrazio Grazie mille Spero di
avervi trasmesso
quello che è realmente la nutrizione
Grazie ancora grazie